We live in a wonderful world, full of life, full of color, full of beauty.
But in recent years, our world has been devastated by hurricanes, earthquakes, floods and droughts.
What does the future hold for planet earth, the place we all call home?
Climate change could destroy the world that we live in.
Scientists predict that within 50 years, many parts of our world could be under 20 centimeters of water.
We can prevent this if we all work together.
There is still time for us to save our world!
Solar panels, wind farms and underwater turbines are being used to produce renewable energy.
These are sources that can be used again and again.
Although there are still many more things that we can be doing.
Things that you and your family can do together.
You can reduce the amount of waste you produce.
This can be done by being more resourceful with the things that you use and buy.
You and your family can recycle many items in your home.
Just look at what you can reuse.
Jars, bottles, bags.